hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash candy wrappers they all taste so
good
instead of throwing your trash on the
floor won't you please give it to me
thank you for considering your fellow
patrons good evening everybody
there is no video for this episode I
apologize everybody on YouTube go watch
to dub
if you don't want to listen if you don't
want to watch I apologize I got to go to
Raleigh North Carolina tomorrow I got to
fly out at 10:00 a.m. at LAX I had a set
tonight at the Comedy Store it was a lot
of fun there was a woman in the crowd
and I said hey and I do a joke about
being sober I said how long have you
been sober she goes five months I said
why did you get sober and she goes well
I put myself in a wheelchair
so that brought the mood down
considerably quite a bit but I am an
expert at what I do I brought it right
back up we had a hell of a good [ __ ]
times when the best says I've had in LA
probably the best that I had at the
store but the result of that is it is
now what time is it been 1246 a it's
1240 6 a.m. this is when we do our best
work ok it's 12:40 6 a.m. we can't sit
on the porch at 1:00 a.m. and scream and
yell on the porch ok because been as
neighbors and and they think they have
jobs these people which counts they
believe they have jobs they probably go
somewhere and do something you know
Ben's out Ben's not in LA so these
people actually might have jobs this is
not you know we're not in there one
other part of Hollywood where people are
really delusional we're out here with
real people real families you know
losers
pretty much
people just you know I was trying to
talk [ __ ] with a friend today and they
didn't hate the right people so many
people don't even know who to hate
especially people that are bitter and
resentful which is many of the people I
know but they don't even hate the right
people they don't even know who to hate
and you got to tell them like you're
wasting your time hating these people
hate these people I'm not telling you
like I was in a meeting today with my
agents in LA and I'm sitting there and I
was complaining them I go you know it's
kind of depressing for comedy fans
people that enjoy comedy with the
climate right now because we see a lot
of stuff out there whether it's late
night TV whether it's political talk
shows that we don't find funny like if
you're a fan of comedy you don't find it
funny and they're like you know one of
my agents was like well we could point
out the deficit in the market or we
could speak to the deficit of money said
okay yeah
I want to speak to the deficit in the
market would any of the accounting
departments that the networks like to
speak to me would they like to speak to
me and we could all talk
yeah I'm fully prepared to speak to the
deficit in the market along with
thousands of other funny people who get
told to go [ __ ] themselves all the time
constantly well no we don't want to just
point it out we're here to work we've
showed up to work we're here we're ready
to go
you know do you am I telling these
people to go [ __ ] off now it's just
nobody has any guts nobody has any balls
and yet maybe you're listening to this
you're like dude those are really affect
me oh shut up cares
it's your entertainment - that sucks out
there
that's milquetoast crap that's garbage
you know you got to sit through this
[ __ ] and you don't really and you don't
you turn it off and you come listen to
things like this you watch it and that's
good I'm happy about that
this shows grown tremendously I'm happy
that people are contributing to the
patreon we're still making funny videos
we're pushing the envelope we're trying
to get people to laugh at [ __ ] up [ __ ]
to bring attention to [ __ ] you know
we're you know we're trying to make
satire about things that are actually
happening okay I didn't watch SNL I
don't know if that's not even tried to
do Epstein
I don't know so maybe I'm wrong about
that I maybe they did I mean you know I
don't know and I don't want to I don't
want to say that they didn't and then
have somebody you know but I would
imagine that their take was not my take
I'll guarantee you that I guarantee that
they didn't do what we did but we're
trying to satirize the world as it
exists you know and it's very tough to
do that and I was sitting in the room my
agent he goes he goes can I give you a
bad idea can I give you a bad idea and I
looked at him and I said I would be
shocked and saddened if you didn't god I
would be surprised if a few bad ideas
did not leave you know and these aren't
bad people these are good people
maybe they listen to this show maybe
they don't who the [ __ ] knows they
probably know they probably googled me
five minutes before I walk in who's the
fat one again
gay fat bring him in yeah but he was on
a tour bus right okay bring him in maybe
they listen to show they're not bad
people
he runs the gamut over there you got a
kinnor D skeletal nerd and then have
like the bro next to him who's an
unscripted he's a kook I'm the
unscripted guy you know cuz he's not a
fan of reading the good-looking dude you
know nice family I get it everybody
wants to make money you know but it's
like you know he said to me some one of
them does
you know he's like can I give you bad
idea I'm like sure he's like what if
it's like you doing [ __ ] you're not good
at like it's just you like you find
Michael Phelps and then you know he's
trying to teach you swim and you don't I
mean come on you know and I'm like you
whatever I'll do that get me money to do
that I will do I don't have any
standards anymore it's all bad the earth
is burning I don't care yes yes I'm in
what about if it was you and like you're
in a tub and we're recreating Whitney
Houston's death yes good
I will recreate celebrity deaths how
about that we'll do that John Belushi
Farley Whitney Houston
I will recreate celebrity Odie's and
suicides and well that'll be the show I
don't care anymore I can't take any of
it seriously anymore
none of it matters it's all bad they're
likely this you got to work with this
guy he's doing Blake Griffin's new show
on so it's what it is it's gonna be his
bub it'll be like Blake Griffin and like
he like he goes and does stuff with
celebrities I got listen to me I will do
whatever you want me to do this Blake
Griffin want to throw a basketball up my
face till I start bleeding is that what
we want to do I'll do it
sign me up I don't it does I don't have
to like it anymore I don't have to think
it's good I don't have to enjoy it
whatever you want to this podcast I
enjoy the things I make on my own I
enjoy whatever jobs you have let me know
what the jobs are the other day is there
a job for janitor in this building can i
push your broom around this building
let's start here
forget the TV [ __ ] forget the
pie-in-the-sky shed can I do anything in
the building is there maintenance work
that needs to be done in the building
currently is air-conditioning
working let's start there maybe let's
not let's not get out and lose our minds
here start talking about Network deals
and just let me know
you know like did the new show Phoebe
Robinson who's sweet girl I know it's
fine good gets a show on Comedy Central
she's gonna do good do things with
celebrity well folks what what happened
no one wants to see celebrities doing
anything did anyone in any focus group
answer that question and say I want to
see Nicki Minaj go to the Olive Garden
who are these people
that's why I don't want to live on the
planet with them but are these real is
this a real or are we just shoving this
down people's throats as per usual and
people have no idea and they just come
home from their soul-crushing job and
they take a handful of pills and they
just veg out on the couch and they no
one asks them what they want
whose idea all these shows which
celebrities do they post Malone and
Jimmy Fallon go to the olive go why why
are they going to the Olive Garden
who are we mocking the people that eat
there the people that we're - sounds
like oh my god have you ever been here
you can see all of gone so much cocaine
I don't know where I am
they've chained me to this desk so I
don't bite someone's tit um you know I'm
just curious out there why this is a
genre of television comedians what are
we supposed to be doing humanizing the
celebrities we're supposed to be showing
the fun human side of people what is
this you know every
is worse than the idea that came before
and you just sit in these rooms I had a
meeting the other day and you know I got
we went to go to the Soho House and
these are nice people that you meet with
these none of these are like they're not
bad people I don't know them but they're
they're all just trying to work in this
hell that we've created so it's not it's
not like anybody is like specifically
the problem the problem is everything
and then these guys who have wives and
kids or husband or whatever they have
they got to all work and earn a living
and I get it okay so none of them are
specifically the issue right a meeting
in this so in the Soho House is like
this private club that has you know LA
and New York and Miami and I think they
have it all over the world and people
pay like five grand a year to just go to
this you know place that's nice-looking
and all these dilettante hang out there
which is like people that think they're
in the entertainment business some of
them are some of them are hanging on
some of them want to be and you know
that's what it is it's not an elite
private club like the Knickerbocker or
the Metropolitan in New York where they
like plan presidential assassinations
and fun stuff it's not that [ __ ] it's
like this oh-ho-ho it's like coke in the
bathroom Oh movie night you know all
these [ __ ] it's a social club for coked
out you know delusional sociopath
running around LA they want to put them
in a place so I go there I'm talking to
somebody and they go you know yeah you
know online it seems like everything's
you know really bad and falling apart
but you know in the real world
everything's fine and I'm like did this
is not you've never been in the real
world have you ever taken a vacation to
the real world you're sitting in a
private club when you walk through the
garage to get in here every cars a
Ferrari a Bentley a Rolls Royce a
Maserati these are the richest people on
planet earth the wealthiest most
privileged most frivolous in many cases
human beings our planet you walk in
these vine stars that kids I recognize
from chasing Cameron that Netflix
documentary
well those young kids is like these
good-looking kids just you know made
fortunes because they they put a bunch
of chicks in a room and they just got on
stage with water bottles and started
throwing water bottles around and
they're all [ __ ] millionaires and
they're just sitting there so Hoskins
they're bored and I'm begging to get a
show on the air I'm begging to work I'm
like i-i've do characters and I uh I
ride and I podcast and I do stand-up and
like I'm the pig you know like I'm like
I like to have all these talents that's
like unattractive and then it's just the
vine kids that are sitting there like
yeah man just were you doing like
survive dude it's like a vibe you know
yeah I
you don't know what to do anymore you
everything is right you try for an hour
late as these billboards it's like for
your Emmy consideration the darisha the
for your Emmy considerate what I mean
the who's watching the Emmys the people
in Ohio whose kids are but they've
barricaded themselves in their bathrooms
because their children are trying to get
in and steal the rest of their back
medication and then finally their child
leaves he steals their car and they're
like thank God Jr's gone I can settle in
and watch the Emmys I wonder who will
get it I hope veep
I hope they who are these people that
are still watching award shows in this
time I put a little literally explain to
me who the people are that are still
emotionally invested in an award show
who's gonna win Best Supporting Actress
the world I mean you'd have to be and I
know people still watch frivolous [ __ ]
I'm not saying you shouldn't I know we
need escapism but could there be any
like sports is real it's a real
compensate could there be anything less
important then who a bunch of old white
fox
who probably all have frequent flyer
miles from Jeffrey Epstein's plane who
they decided was Best Supporting Actress
this year could anything matter less and
there's all these billboards in LA for
your Emmy consideration
please remember The Daily Show with
Trevor Noah
remember us for your Emmy kids here
under these billboards our tent cities
of homeless people there's like
dysentery like there's there's diseases
from the Oregon Trail or back because of
the filth because of the absolute out of
filth people have walking around with
cholera yes yellow fever and we're
talking before you're a me consider a
for your consideration who is
considering this what psychopath is
putting one thought into this I mean
well it's pretty good things are pretty
good here everyone's got a Maserati it's
like I will say this many of you who are
fans of the program know that I have had
many negative and accurate things to say
about the restaurant swingers in West
Hollywood I do not mind the swingers in
Santa Monica although I believe it is
ridiculous because both swingers
restaurants are these like faux 1950's
like retro diner I don't like I don't
like that I'm not into that this like
nostalgia diner
I love diners they're an East Coast
thing that's really what they are I mean
there's some cool ones on the west coast
he'd have been around forever fine but
swingers was opened in the 90s and
swingers is on Beverly Boulevard and
like the food at swingers is atrocious
and the service of swingers is
incompetent and rude and but those are
not my biggest issues with swingers
my biggest issue with swingers is that
they are running a human trafficking
ring out of the West Hollywood location
that is my biggest issue that they are
party to the rape murder and torture of
children now I haven't spoken out about
this before because I didn't have all
the facts now that I've gotten all the
facts I am 100% certain that swingers in
West Hollywood is running a human
trafficking ring out of their shitty
retro diner okay that people that did go
on seeking arrangement states decide how
much money should be exchanged before
they go eat each other's [ __ ]
they're running a human trafficking ring
what's the evidence okay I'm glad you
asked number one it's in Hollywood
that's most of the evidence I have but
it ain't nothing okay okay the men us
and we get the menu up band the swingers
menu please cuz they you know I went
there the other day because I have to
keep going there because I live by there
and I went there the other Oh early bird
special early bird special I wonder what
that means early bird special
interesting
BYO omelet what the hell is it BYO
omelet bind your orphan omelet is that
what BYO stands for bind your orphan so
they're selling orphans that you get to
tie up well I'm not for that I'm not for
that sorry
call me a square I'm
for the Edwin's posture who the hell is
Edwin someone they [ __ ] to death I'm
telling you folks I went there the other
day and the woman waitress confronted me
about some of the stuff I'd said on the
podcast she didn't do it directly of
course and by the way I am nice to
servers I tip well stop this [ __ ] that
I'm not nice to start very nice to
servers and he at real servers are in
New York City and they take pride in
their service okay they're not these
people that are throwing avocado toast
at you waiting teeth for their band to
get signed cut it out
I'm very nice to service I always tip
well okay and why do I tip well I know
because without exception all servers
are drug addicts and they take my tip
and they go buy pills and I know that
it's every single server okay it's
crushing up adderall in the back of that
restaurant and I I don't want to deny
them that opportunity so I tipped them
nice but the problem is the woman was
like she said something to me shake I'm
glad you had your breakfast
I bet glad you got some new material I
mean breakfast and I said haha I said oh
do you listen to Joe because I've heard
about it I say well good I appreciate
all my listeners okay you know I'd
rather them not run human trafficking
rings out of a diner and I'm not a guy
that would ever be like I don't don't go
on their Yelp don't [ __ ] on them don't
do any of that none of that will fix the
real problem you know what I mean so if
you're gonna take action take real
action you know don't go on Yelp if
you're gonna if you're gonna do it do it
folks of course I'm kidding this is a
bit but it is a horrific restaurant and
I was accosted there by rude thoughtless
and ignorant waitress who is humorless
losers are always humorless by the way
they can never take a joke
people make jokes about me all the time
whatever blah blah blah I don't care
doesn't matter but the people that
swingers can't handle the truth okay no
we don't want your tofu meatloaf burn in
hell
no one needs that you [ __ ] sucks and
yeah at this podcast a lot of people
listen to it it's really grown and
they're not thrilled that I've talked
very accurately about their restaurant
and I have an email list I just sent an
email to my whole email is saying please
do not go to swingers or West Hollywood
I'm currently in a feud with them go to
another restaurant if you need it I will
post other restaurants in the area that
you can go to okay
oh but swimmer's is open 24 hours where
am I gonna get late-night food go to bed
go to bed go to [ __ ] swingers see
swingers it's as hot off the girdle
doesn't say griddle there it says girdle
what is that and then there's on the
menu it says hot off the girdle and then
under that it looks like there's some is
that Japanese writing yeah I will say if
you look at the menu of swingers first
of all they put Tina turn-on to me get
pina Turner off your goddamn menu the
woman's an icon when the [ __ ] was she in
swingers when the [ __ ] was she eating it
swingers people are full of [ __ ] she's
not there
the [ __ ] lives in Switzerland you just
takes celebrities and place them all
over your menu sewers in Hollywood shut
up so I mean that's where I'm at with
them I'm not gonna go there anymore I'm
not gonna go I did like their vegan
banana pancakes with chocolate chips I
still may go to the Santa Monica
location because just a blogger that me
and Ben like who sits here every day cuz
he he's basically homeless
he's a centrist and it's a very hard
time to be a centrist and he basically
just he's withering away
and we bought him food one day didn't we
buy him dinner yeah we about him dinner
we bought him dinner and he got an
attitude he was sad he was upset we
bought him dinners like what did you do
that for cuz you're harmless we're
trying to be nice to you this is why
folks you have to be very careful about
who you do for out there because there's
a lot of people out there they just
don't want the help you know you just
don't want that so I'm just saying my
personal problem with swingers is that
they are running a human trafficking
ring that's my biggest problem with them
is that they're running a pedophile ring
in West Hollywood that's my biggest
issue a close second would be the
meatloaf is dry and they don't know the
difference between appetizer and entree
they don't know what to bring out when
and they're kind of clueless and you
know they you know all the chicks there
it's like how many tattoos does one body
need let's be honest how many tattoos is
what can you all stop with the tattoos
they're disgusting they really are I
know that a lot of people that listen to
this probably have tattoos you know fine
and I'm sure sometimes some people they
look good but there's a lot of people
out there well your arm is just covered
in [ __ ] it just looks like you're
covered in [ __ ] that's what it looks
like
you can barely afford to get good tattoo
and then you got to go get the tattoos
covered up and we're fixed you got to
get them fixed and filled in and you got
to make one tattoo into another tattoo
because it didn't work you didn't have
the money to finish it and it's Blake
hey guys hey how about you cut it out
stop painting yourself find something
else to do okay you're never gonna get
buried in a Jewish cemetery but you know
who can Jeffrey Epstein years not that
does Jeffy boy he's got no tats
Jeff folks we've talked about it before
many of you are not going to be able to
get out of your current situation unless
you [ __ ] your way out of it okay
got to go lay that pipe with a woman
who's gonna inherit a house that's it
we're not talking about an estate either
we're just talking about a little
split-level in Tempe Arizona
I don't even even know if they have
split-levels there they probably live in
some you know but those Adobe [ __ ] also
cares a little mother-daughter something
you know her mom left it to her you get
to move in with her that's what you're
gonna do many of you that's your only
hopes your only chance really
okay that's it you're not gonna win big
at the casino you're not gonna finish
your novel and if you do and it's the
greatest thing that's ever been written
no one won't care so get real learn how
to lay some real pipe and we got to talk
about blue chew because blue chew is all
the same ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but it's much easier to get they
have doctors online you don't have to go
to a doctor it doesn't have to be
awkward they'll ship it to your house
and discreet packaging it's not gonna be
one of those situations where you feel
bad about not getting hard you know I
know that people get upset about that
too like well III feel self-conscious
about it it's like enough enough why not
take a drug people don't feel
self-conscious about taking other drugs
they just do it they do it because they
want optimal performance and that's what
you need to have you need optimal
performance okay it's great
the online physician consultation is
free and are these people real doctors
who gives a [ __ ]
it only takes a few minutes to connect
with a blue true calm affiliated
physician if you qualify you get
prescribed online quickly you don't have
to go anywhere just chew it and do it
visit blue comma get your first order
free dude
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you if you
use promo code that are not promo code
TD you just pay five dollars shipping
that's blue2 com promote Edie and it's
only five dollars shipping why would you
not do this why would you not be a
little harder
you know blue chew is where it's at if
Jeffrey have seen that blue chew I
guarantee you know
maybe things would have worked out
differently you know maybe not you know
don't get it if you're a pedophile don't
do that the last thing I want on my
conscience there's a bunch of pedophiles
with hard dicks if you're a pedophile
keep your dick soft okay don't be
running around with a big hard dick but
you know people people people need to
look at sex as a way to get to the next
level in life it's very important okay
you want you want to get out of your
current situation learn how to [ __ ]
really good it's an asset I have friends
that are very good-looking and they [ __ ]
good and they have good lives and it's
not because you're talented or
interesting it's not because they worked
hard it's not because they dedicated
themselves it's because they [ __ ] good
and some chicks like well I just want to
[ __ ] you you know or if you're gay guy
you could the [ __ ] older hawk I've it
owns a house you know you know I'm out
here trying to change the world with my
comedy because I'm a genius
but the world is not meant for people
like me it's meant for people with hard
dicks people with empty heads people
that are morally bankrupt and I assume
that those people go very far but you
gotta have a hard dick I'm telling you
that's why Italians always had big dicks
but they're not that smart because God
took a piece of their brain and put it
in their penis
that's why Italians have big dicks but
they're not that intelligent but it's
much better to just have a big hard dick
than to be smart what are you really
getting by being smart in this world
well I mean come on it's almost an
impediment to be quite honest with you
you gotta really know how to put that
intelligence to use otherwise you're
just some babbling idiot that's smart
there's a [ __ ] if you're smart go to
blue chewed
komm promo code TD $5 shipping into
first-order free try it folks it works I
saw that there's a there's another thing
in Hollywood I've seen there's a
billboard look this up and there's a
show about songwriters in Hollywood this
is hilarious by the way this is one of
my favorite things there's going to be a
show a show on networks where
songwriters are gonna compete to see
yeah song land I mean but folks folks
song land song land is coming to NBC now
I know my fans all love bring the funny
on NBC because a comedians get to
disgrace themselves on national
television in front of genius Chrissy
Teigen you know nobody knows comedy
better than Chrissy Teigen
okay John Legend's wife right that's her
credit that's what she's brought to the
table she's married John what else has
she done Chrissy she's just like a
Twitter Queen you know yeah tweets about
avocados good good for her well she
knows what's funny and what's not right
so she gets to judge you on on and ELISA
there's a very funny people that did
bring the funny oh she's a Sports
Illustrated Sports Illustrated swimsuit
model so she gets it she knows and you
know so she's sitting there and bring
the funny and then funny people I like
and respect have to go out there okay
and they have to get judged by a Sports
Illustrated supports Illustrated
swimsuit model okay I mean god only
knows what this [ __ ] thinks is funny
who what what does she think is funny
you know
who gives a [ __ ] who are you go right on
that joy look a [ __ ]
who are you you're hot [ __ ] if you look
like me you would be pushing a shopping
cart full of cans into a can exchange
and you'd be putting them in AB oisin
and you'd be getting quarters back
but instead you're on bring the funny
telling people that have worked their
asses off getting good at something not
just showing up with tents showing up
with tits in the tan people have spent
years in nightclubs and shitty [ __ ]
rooms training and getting good at
something you get to tell them that they
were a little off they were a little off
tonight
okay bring the funny we don't need the
funny this world does not need more
clowns we don't need the funny the last
thing this country needs is more
goofballs
okay we got a lot we got some deadly
serious issues you know who's the next
goofball bring the funny bring the funny
- Chrissy Teigen and she'll let you know
if you're good or not you know it's the
same thing with what's-her-name on
America's Got Talent
Heidi Klum sitting there telling people
they suck you know thank God you were
hot huh be a real fun life if you
weren't what what would you be if you
were four foot two what would you be
I'll tell you what you'd be you beating
out back in Tallahassee getting screamed
at by a customer who said they ordered a
bloomin onion 20 minutes ago and you'd
be sweating and you'd be panicked and
you would be like you'd be like I don't
know I think the kitchen is but I'm
sorry two kitchens backed up and they're
you there be your breath some fat woman
be like [ __ ] but instead you're hot and
you're six feet tall so you get to sit
and tell everyone else they suck that's
what you get to know if I was that hot I
would just I would be hot and I'd be
rich because people [ __ ] you when your
heart and they [ __ ] you with money they
don't even [ __ ] you with their date they
[ __ ] you with money here here come
houses cars
there you go vacations it's one long
orgasm your whole [ __ ] life but these
people have to sit there and judge
others
you know bring the funny should be
judged by trolls ugly trolls people who
need comedy ugly beasts should judge
that show people that actually give up
but actually listen and need to laugh
okay that show should be judged by
people who've been to horrendous
personal tragedy that's who the show
should be judged by people 911s too far
away to have lost somebody those people
have probably gotten over it bring the
funny should be judged by people who've
lost someone within the last two months
make them laugh and I mean more than one
per slight a woman her husband this was
an amazing story he was like a hero he
saved her two daughters and he died in a
Riptide
that woman should be judging bring the
funny okay and she probably sucks too
she'd probably tell me it's too dark
[ __ ] your husband just died you can't
get into this it's too dark
I don't want so song land is now coming
the newest where where the idea by the
way listen to the music that's out there
know who's writing this who is writing
visa debt does your cat's lyrics up to
juicy let's see what song land is get
doja cat juicy because this is get the
lyrics up these this is the caliber of
songwriter that's it's gonna win the
show
listen ready so the whole show's about
writing songs now go-to song land on NBC
because we're gonna read these lyrics go
to song land on NBC song land is
American songwriting competition it's it
sets out to give undiscovered
songwriters the chance to create a hit
which I'm sure by the way NBC will then
own okay it gives the viewers a look at
the creative process in action go to the
juicy lyrics the creative process I keep
it juicy juicy
I eat that lunch she keep that booty
booty she keep the
plump the natural beauty beauty yeah
yeah if you could see it from the front
wait till you see it from the back back
back back back and it's not a bad song
juicy it's a catchy song but what are
you talking about
song right the creative process he liked
the dozier with the cat yeah he liked it
thick he liked it fat yeah what creative
process are you shining a light on NBC
what are you talking about I keep it
juicy juicy
I eat that lunch she keep that booty
booty she keep that plump what I really
want to see the behind-the-scenes look
at the brilliant songwriters the
lyricists who were able to like come up
with these lyrics
what rhymes ah what rhymes with lunch ah
plump right well the songs about an ass
right yeah the song is about an ass okay
so we got up so the songs have been an
ass so we just we have to kind of
describe an ass for the whole song right
I mean the chorus is got to talk about
the ass and then you know so we got to
just come up with so we got booty we got
plump I keep it juicy juicy I eat that
lunch so that's a nice lyric because you
think eat it because we're talking about
an ass so eating an ass eating lunch his
lunch someone's ass that you're reading
or maybe she eats that lunch so she
keeps her ass fat she has that lunch she
goes and she has a lunch she's not
vomiting in the bathroom some bony white
girl ass she's got a nice fat ass
because she eats the lunch go down here
how long it take to pull and all them n
words want to know how long it takes to
pull my
pants up broke a fingernail and then
some trying to squeeze into my True
Religion denim mm-hmm
celibate don't want to cellulite I don't
buy it with a cellulite I don't even
know this sounds like it was written by
like a speech you know one of those
things like one of those programs it
takes your words and then spits them out
what I call that speech-to-text it
sounds like it was written by a
speech-to-text thing that like the
malfunction it's like picking up every
third word because this doesn't make
sense it's like baby talk it's like boo
bootie lunch plump celibate cellulite it
what NBC's gonna have a competition show
where people are gonna what do you think
they're gonna write Dylan's masters of
war what do you think is gonna happen
undiscovered songwriters what
psychopaths are those I want to write a
song like juicy I just want us to write
a song like juicy I gotta keep working
go back to song land for a second I want
to see who's gonna be judging this I'm
sure it'll be people that have no
[ __ ] idea you know judging song land
Kourtney Kardashian a beagle each
episode producers Ryan Tedder ester dean
and shane mcanally will team up with the
songwriter to create the next big hit to
be recorded by guest performing artists
for seemingly unknown storm riders
audition songs they've written by
singing them live it's enlightening the
CEO song can just change by slowing it
down or speeding it up or moving the
chorus or emphasizing the beat or
shuffling parts around
interesting song land attempts to rework
the often thankless and grueling job of
thought songwriting the general public
rarely knows who wrote the lyrics or the
music to catch it tech because they're
horrible no one asks who wrote I eat the
lunch here's my fat ass
don't you like my fat ass in your face
no one cares the lyrics don't matter it
doesn't matter what they're saying they
don't even have to be lyrics she could
just go fat as fat as juicy juicy fat
ass here's my fat ass no one cares I
love that the general public really
knows who wrote the lyrics yeah no one's
riding in their cargo I wonder who wrote
that I eat that lunch I keep it plump oh
I wonder who wrote that yeah there's a
good reason the show tries to elevate to
judicial role the songwriter in the
process of creating music from
unpleasant secret to being sell to being
a celebrated magic ingredient good luck
good [ __ ] luck
and good for mrs. cat I'm not hating on
her I'm not hating on dosha cat and what
she's been able to accomplish that's the
move now people want to know how to get
big have a fat ass have a fat ass and
we'll figure the rest now I did that I
have a fat ass and I could barely get a
meeting have a fat ass don't have a lot
of cellulite on it have it be real fat
have it look like an Eddie Bauer leather
seat in a Ford Explorer come in with
that and we'll write the song around it
we'll get your stylist we'll figure it
out you lead with the ass
bring the ass in I can imagine all these
executives sitting and the thing just
looking at girls asses all day that's
the one we want
badass pops well we'll we'll back into
her career see what I did there we'll
back into the song let's just let's
let's choose an ass let's choosing it oh
she's got a pockmarked face out give me
an ass with a nice face and I'll make a
star give me a fat ass and a nice face
and I will make you a star
song land I think my agent over today
and I heard somebody downstairs like
playing an acoustic guitar and I'm like
oh there's some some somebody's in there
like playing a guitar like for the agent
or something like trying I was it what
and I was like I hope it's Shawn Mendes
I hope it's a big celebrity who's
nothing sadder than like some
disinterested la agent sitting there and
like some guy being like this is about
my grandma died in Portland and it's
about I had a really rough time and then
I met this girl and she really changed
it but she's dead now and here's my song
it's like putty what's your ass like
take your pants off we're not playing it
we don't care anymore what are you
saying let me ask you a question yeah
let me ask you a question so uh yeah and
then I just you know I just really start
to come to terms with my diction I wrote
this beautiful song about connecting
with who I am sir let me ask you a
question do you keep it juicy what do
you eat that lunch what if if I can see
it from the front can I see it from the
back I don't understand exactly get the
[ __ ] out of my office go to Nashville
and go kill yourself because this is not
gonna work you don't get what we're
doing here nobody's interested in your
[ __ ] story do you keep it juicy do
you eat that lunch I mean this is you
know I mean these people are and then
you gotta you gotta act like
everything's you know gotta act like
everything's great
we're in the golden era let's talk about
Monday calm okay Monday calm Monday calm
cuz he's always at Monday's in there
folks my Monday is tomorrow Thursday
when I fly to start when I fly to the
club and I check-in I got hi I'm the
clown when they go well
we have a show tonight two shows
tomorrow two shows a Saturday and my
weekend is your week my Thursday is your
Monday but Monday is coming if you own a
business you need software like Monday
comm because it allows you very easily
to keep track of everything that you're
doing stay organized find files look
looking through emails and finding [ __ ]
is a nightmare I've told you this before
my lack of organization has prevented my
success and everything I've ever done if
I was an organized human being
me and Ben would be able to do so much
more I'm only starting to get organized
now Ben's only starting get organized
now he's only been sober for a little
over a year before that he was like
blackout drunk walking down to 405
okay so he's synapses are only starting
to fire and occasionally connect the
point is we're not really organized we
doing a podcast now at 2:00 a.m. in a
garage we had four days to do this but
I'm all over the [ __ ] place I'm
living in the middle of a divorce that I
moved into okay in the room of a 19 year
old girl who's living in New York I'm
living in her room and I'm then that fat
cat Oscar keeps trying to escape and I'm
[ __ ] charged with keeping him he said
the police called on him several times
he's a [ __ ] terrorist he's crazy he
keeps finding ways to get out he's been
doing it for years
it's hack at this point you just can't
[ __ ] and if I was organized folks I'd
have it all down I'd have it all down
I'd have nine pilots written would it
matter no they'd all tell me to [ __ ]
myself anyway but it would be nice at
least I'd be getting told to [ __ ] myself
with so the point is never go to Monday
calm okay Monday calm slash Tim Monday
calm slash Tim they get a free you get a
free 14-day trial there's no commitment
checkout Monday cop see for yourself how
helpful their software is what's great
about these ads is there's no commitment
dummies so if you don't like it leave
they've given you a 14-day free trial
the other swell for work it creates
accountability nobody can say they
didn't get the email nobody can say they
missed the meeting everything is there
everything's connected everything's easy
and if you find a way to make your
business more efficient it might succeed
you know all that Gary Vaynerchuk said
hustle grind go get them attack the day
kill it crush it [ __ ] it's dead body
whatever it is you got to do it and
Monday dot-com / Tim is a way to do it
you get a 14-day free trial ok it's easy
I'm so on an organ donor where anything
is I just checked in for my flight it's
leaving in seven hours you know god I
don't want to go I don't want to get on
a plane I want to stay I don't want to
go to work
but this is my Monday many of you feel
that way too you know that's the way it
is folks Monday comm / Tim 14-day free
trial try it out see what you like if
you have a fledgling business you need
this help check it out see if you like
if you don't like it you could parties
friends no big deal not a problem
they'll commitment if you do like it
it's a great way for small business to
really grow ok fail because your content
sucks don't fail because you're not
organized many of you will fail but fail
because you don't bring anything to the
table fail because you're not good
enough smart enough fast enough sharp
enough fail because you don't want it
down deep you don't have the fire in you
you're not a competitor you're not a
fighter you're not a winner fail because
you can't close the deal you can't make
the sale you're a loser
you're everything your father thought
you are fail because of that but know
that for sure don't fail because
somebody didn't get an email it seems
like a dumb reason to fail put it all on
the line take the risks then fail jump
jump and don't look down and then when
you finally look down you realize that
you're about to fall into a pit of
knives with snakes or whatever
it's late but have that be the reason
you fail don't fail by accident don't
fail because it's a managerial [ __ ] fail
because you just suck you know um Monday
comm / Tim 14-day free trial don't [ __ ]
around get it get it set it and forget
it
be efficient be a businessman Europe
you're a business you are you hear that
you sitting there you're eating Domino's
you're sitting in your room you're a
business you don't even know it you're a
goddamn business but you just need
Monday comm I'm gonna get Monday comm
and I'm gonna organize myself so that
when I fail I'm gonna know it's cuz of
me it's not because of some clerical
error you sit down with your wife and
she goes what happened with the business
we haven't trouble getting organized or
was it overwhelming good no no it
actually ran smoothly honey I suck you
married a loser you married a zero and
then she'll take a sip of coffee and go
oh okay but Monday comm work and you go
great Monday comm was great but I'm a
loser and shield oh yeah I kind of
thought and yoga well now we know for
sure cuz it wasn't it wasn't the
clerical issues it was me it was your
husband Monday dot-com / Tim get the
[ __ ] trial don't start
you know I should own boomers a lot man
but at least they had good [ __ ] music
and all these people that are like you
real political ideologues now and they
all [ __ ] on the Boomers and I [ __ ] on
the Boomers but listen guys what do you
think you're gonna bake the boomers were
idealistic too didn't work the system
won the system is probably sadly gonna
win again I know that nobody wants to
hear that but that's what's gonna happen
and you could tell all these kids years
from now how you thought you memed your
way to victory and you got nothing and
nothing really changed and nobody really
gives a [ __ ]
had Bernie sandals get into office and
we'll get we'll have free Community
College because everybody will fight him
tooth and nail you know and just like
Obama remember that Obama was like hey
you know that guy fought for eight years
and got you know you got like a health
care plan where you've got like $30 off
cancer or something you got like a
Groupon if every one of your family had
cancer you had a Groupon so you could go
and not you know whatever was but that's
what it is and like you know if you've
been through around a few cycles and
you've you've seen what it is and you've
seen the bastardization of pop culture
you've seen it to generate into it
through a literal sewer I mean literally
the words and these songs you this baby
talk it's bigger I have a googoo gah-gah
a boo-boo Baba look at my ass I'm hidden
it's baby talk it it doesn't make any
sense
it's literally googoo gaga baby talk
mush brain someone who was in a car
accident who can barely understand I
mean these songs sound like the people
that are writing them or you're showing
them flashcards to teach them the
language after they've had a stroke
booty lunch pump I mean I mean so it's a
sewer it's a sewer out there
and everybody wants to just go see they
want to go see what celebrities are
doing they want to go to the bowling
alley with cardi B that's what they want
to do they want to see celebrities do
things that you have to do in your
shitty life isn't it fun to see
celebrities do things that we do because
we have no [ __ ] choice because we got
to go to the [ __ ] Olive Garden
because it's the only thing in this town
that was polluted by poison that the
government tested missiles in we're
living in a missile silo and the only
thing here is the Olive Garden so it
would be real fun it'll be real fun if
we could see Cameron Diaz go and eat
there make us feel a lot better about
having our tour of Italy it's from
people you're an audience for that did
people request that like by the way it
would really make me feel better if we
can see celebrities doing the horrific
things I'm forced to do on a daily basis
what's the next show you know Amy Adams
goes and works at a private prison next
next on Seth Meyers
see Amy Adams work at a private juvenile
detention center won't that be fun I bet
that'll be that'll be funny let's go see
it
that should be fun
Liam Hemsworth goes and works in a sober
house who's sober who's lying
Liam we'll see you see Liam Hemsworth
three addicts with Forks trying to kill
Liam Hemsworth that I would watch if
that if that is a show I'm not pitching
things I would absolutely watch you know
but I mean this new genre of tits like
it doesn't make any sense to me I gotta
sit in these rooms and look at these
people with a straight face and not like
I just have to look at them and nod and
go yeah yeah that sounds good that
sounds fun sounds
you know it's a great show
so what Madonna's gonna do if she's
gonna go make biochemical weapons with
Raytheon they're their missiles put the
warhead has biochemical agents in it so
Madonna's gonna do that it's real fun
it's real fun she she takes you to the
whole Factory and you get to see the
plant where they make all the missiles
it's great oh yeah that sounds fun
Madonna's you know 85 years old I'm sure
they're not gonna choose her she's
another one that corpse she comes out
and I haven't seen her in a while Tina
Turner did it right kill four years be
the best leave the country leave the
country
you did it you dude you did it and you
said you watched something on CBS Sunday
morning
yeah and she would you said she was uh
she was kind of nice about Ike but she
was like well you got to understand with
Ike he was also very sweet to me he was
very loving in the beginning giving me
gifts always loving armies I mean she's
kind of defended him in the interview
really let me listen Ike Ike's methods
much like Joe Jackson's methods were not
ideal but if if it's a choice between
Tina Turner Michael Jackson and I I eat
that lunch I keep it plump then bring
back the beatings bring back the belt
maybe that's the problem nobody feels
the sting of leather when they [ __ ] up
and Billy Eilish sucks you [ __ ]
losers I've tried to listen to this
talentless [ __ ] and she sings about
[ __ ] her friend's dad don't tell me
he's a [ __ ] minor enough I'm a bad
guy Mike [ __ ] your dad what you're
acting like you know who else was - the
Olsen twins they killed Heath
Pledger I forgot which one did that but
one of them dead I'm over it but this
idea that a minor it's garbage
and if people mess even a check I'm like
hey I'm a fan of your podcast but like
actually if you listen to it it's real
early actually if you listen to it it's
really deep and good hey hey [ __ ] off
you go listen to it then Billie Eilish
this is her songs they sound like that
she goes man that's what it sounds like
that's the song can she sing can she
sing anything or is it all a ritual
where she sits there and all these kids
are obsessed with her and you know they
all chant and it's the [ __ ] Hollywood
ball or whatever probably doing bigger
budget stadiums now I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm happy where I am in a garage with
the truth I give a [ __ ] all these
companies tell me to [ __ ] off that's ok
all these people in this town nothing is
bad enough yet
and I don't mean like world [ __ ] I mean
like nothing will ever be bad enough for
them they will make things that are so
bad and the only time they will ever
stop is if the San Andreas Fault just
you know everything and they're
swallowed the only way they will stop
make it bad [ __ ] is if they are
swallowed into the earth I mean or the
great Bill Hicks who said what was it it
splits off in its Arizona Bay LA Arizona
today like there you know you know
should we should we just point out the
deficit in the market or let's speak to
the deficit oh my yeah let's speak to it
let's speak to I'll speak to it let's do
a show let's do something funny
now ya know
he wants to do that okay well then I
guess I'll just have to keep pointing
out the deficit
cuz I'm sorry didn't come up with song
land sorry I didn't I didn't no one
gives a [ __ ] about who writes the songs
songwriters are supposed to be people
that have thankless jobs that make a lot
of money and they have these big
beautiful homes and nobody gives you the
[ __ ] they are cuz it's all magic nobody
wants to know what it really is
stop tryin to show the process to all
these people that don't give a [ __ ]
about it it's not that interesting okay
rhyming plump and bump or whatever
you're doing isn't that [ __ ]
intriguing that there needs to be a
process you know we need to explore the
process of who writes the [ __ ] me let
it be magic let these dumb [ __ ] think
that all these people write their own
songs it's all fake let it be thank
stop trying to like peel the curtain
back so these people can take a look at
how the sausage is made you know how the
sausage is made and in in certain cases
rape and murder extortion blackmail like
peel that curtain back that's why I
really want to say I don't really give a
[ __ ] about the Songwriters okay I want
to know who the [ __ ] Corey Feldman's
talking about for thirty [ __ ] years
or is he full of [ __ ] too that's the
funniest thing me and Ray if you guys I
don't know that we'll get the episode
number but if you're subscribed to the
patron you got to find you gotta find
the episode where me and Ray riff on
Corey Feldman's like Good Morning
America or Today Show appearance it is
one of the funniest things me and Ray
have ever done where we just think about
like it's all these generals that did MK
on all these kids and they see this guy
and they're like we so he's rogue he
went rogue and he's just like dancing
right I mean it's the funniest thing
I've ever seen in my life and Mia ray
but I mean they did this whole idea and
it started with like Louie who is a
genius but it started with that like how
does it happen how do these comedians
come up with their bits
I wonder how is it how does it happen
and all these people like Mike my father
his wife loved to watch the voice and
they loved most people love these
competition shows they watch for people
to fail because it makes them feel good
that they never tried anything they go
see they're going home you're going home
yet an off night it makes them feel good
when they file into their job tomorrow
that they never took a risk in their
[ __ ] life they get they want to see
you go home and then at the end somebody
wins and they get to pretend to feel
happy for that person you know you know
but stop with this [ __ ] it's magic
let it be magic I appreciated it all so
much more when I didn't know any of
these people and I didn't know how any
of this happened and I just thought that
really supremely talented people just
work their asses off and struggled and
got rewarded and now that some of that
is going on but a lot of it isn't and
now that I've seen that a lot of it is
just people that strategize and plot and
which is a skill in and of itself unto
itself and I'm not saying that it is in
a meaningful skill and it's certainly a
hell of a lot better skill than the one
that I have which is just like trying to
be good at a thing that I said I'd be
good at it takes a little bit of the
magic away from it okay so I don't need
to watch song land I don't need to watch
bring the funny I know I know that you
can bring the funny and here's what
happens when you bring the funny people
tell you to go [ __ ] yourself okay hi I
brought the funny oh we didn't order
funny
we ordered a fat ass you're gonna shake
your fat ass today what I brought the
funny wrong Oh we ordered Native
American in a wheelchair we didn't order
funny what no no no no I have the order
right here at the GrubHub order it says
mixed race 19 year old socialist Native
American in a wheelchair and just a fat
ass an ass of fat like a jello mold
not even will will attach it to a person
when we find the right one we just want
the ass now let me ask a question do you
have the ass no I brought the funny you
fool
go deliver post mates bring the funny
bring
gun yeah as always a show is brought to
you by swingers in West Hollywood
swingers you know I mean the food is bad
the service is worse the decor is an
embarrassment the vibe is bad every time
you walk in the vibes not good um you
know what Holly was a real nightmare you
gotta be you gotta be in Hancock Park
you got to have the East Coast a state
gotta have the East Coast Tudor are you
gonna go to got to go to the beach gotta
be Malibu or you got to be Beverly Hills
with a big pink house and your neighbors
are Saudis and they got white tigers
roaming the property West Hollywood
enough enough I dream that booty booty I
eat then I do like that song I do like
and I am opening for I will be opening
for dosha cat all summer I'm excited
about it
I'm kind of curious he's [ __ ] song
land for songwriters we'll see if they
have what it takes to write [ __ ] for
songwriters we'll see if they have what
it takes to write songs and baby talk
for our population whose IQs are
plummeting every year soon it'll just be
sounds good boo boo boo boo boo good oh
that's good what someone did you write I
wrote googa boo boo oh five songwriters
see if they have what it takes to write
[ __ ] for fat asses soothly gonna just
take a microphone and put it right in
the middle of an ass they won't even
would even just gonna be an ass why even
attach these to people we just want the
ass just to shake I'm telling right now
a music video two years will be a
shaking ass it will not even be a human
being why
do we even have human beings for what
for what purpose
Aida booty booty you didn't like it's
catchy the beat is cat the people who do
the music that's a talent it's catchy
it's catchy not everything's catchy it's
interesting I mean that ain't great
either you know hey Bach but it's catchy
you know and uh I'm gonna go to New York
for a few days and record with Ray Lucy
my mother see my father and his wife
take a quick couple of sojourn I don't
want to go that I'm looking at hotels
and it's like it's so weird to have
lived in a place your entire life
and we'll go back to it now and get a
hotel it's an interesting feeling I'm
like you know it was a great deal no
financial district I'm like I don't want
to stay in the front the financial
district is depressing especially when
you don't have any finances it's kind of
depressing really want to stay on Wall
Street okay he's very depressing part of
New York City is just not for me
yeah there's parts of downtown I like
Tribeca the village but the financial
districts whatever but it's 98,000 night
to go down there staying like whatever
Doubletree Hilton some [ __ ] I'll try to
stand by the park I like I like that
area I like the Midtown area the area
where where Alex lives Epstein that area
I kind of like you know I mean Wix Wix
Wix many of you out there have spent
time on your personal brand and it is
why your lives are not what you want
them to be because people cannot
identify what your brand is who are you
what are you why are you what do you
bring to the table can I describe you in
less than three words
what are you fat black nerd okay
angry butch Dyke skinny smart herpes
what are you brand is important it's
more important than anything else right
now you gotta have a very easily
identifiable brand people don't feel
comfortable if you don't have a brand
okay
Jew loud [ __ ]
three words whatever it is okay
happy Indian deli you're a happy ending
guy that works at a deli it's who you
are it's your brand how you interface
with the world it's very important I'm
not saying all Jews are constant they're
all Indians work at delis they are and
they do but that's not what I'm saying
what I'm saying is it's clearly a joke
what I'm saying is that you need a brand
and part of the brand is having a
website I'm part of having a website is
designing one and a lot of you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're doing so if
you go with Wix you can start from
scratch if you want to prove something
or you can choose from five hundred
stunning templates they also have an
innovative drag-and-drop website
builders you can easily customize your
site and they had tax images videos
whatever you want you can even build
your site Wix Adi with their artificial
design intelligence answer a few simple
questions about your business and Wix
will create a stunning website for you
we built Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
Tim Dylan TI ll ons going to hell calm
using wicks it was incredibly easy to do
so if you have business you want to
promote if you have content you want to
promote you need a professional website
okay if people can only contact you via
social media you're missing out on the
like a lot of clients especially boomers
boomers love a website they love the
ability to go to you send you a message
professionally you can put up a few
testimonials on your website you know a
lot of people are photographers you know
a lot of people like to photograph
people and things Photography is also
something people get into when they're
complete losers it's it's like the least
you know it requires nothing you've bug
go buy a camera and you go [ __ ] around
who cares and the pictures are dumb and
it's pointless it's a pointless activity
and the people that don't really have a
lot going on can go out and take photos
or like lakes and you know you put with
all the things on a computer you can
make them look and in a none of it
matters okay none of it matters you have
a meaningless life and taking photos of
your surrounding area is not only is it
not impressive it's a large waste of
your time but many of you need to waste
your time that's all you're gonna do in
fact your entire life from birth to
death will be just different chunks of
how you waste your time okay because
every word that comes out of your mouth
is it people that are listening to it it
is like it is like nails on chalkboard
grading to hear you speak so go and be
quiet go buy a camera and go go shoot
pictures of birds
okay go bother them instead of [ __ ]
sitting around and bothering everybody
with your inane thoughts that a
pointless pointless activity elective
until you ever meet somebody that
doesn't getting really into photography
as soon as somebody says they're getting
really into photography run the other
way there's nothing to get into what are
you talking about everyone's a
photographer everyone you point your
phone at something you go click no
there's good mean raised to have so such
fights about this Israel did so mad at
me because yeah okay there are some good
photographers but let's get [ __ ] real
there's a lot of people out there
wasting the goddamn time they just want
a shiny toy camera they can go out and
play around with it but if you are one
of those heathens put the photos on a
professional website it let's at least
make it look good then maybe somebody
will buy your print of the Long Island
Sound who do you want to buy my print no
they don't but maybe they will get of a
website I'm a professional photography
says who are you Annie Leibovitz oh
you're not getting into photography I've
heard a lot of people say that recently
and it's never people that are
worthwhile it's always people that
should be thrown in a lake
I'm getting into photography you know
when you go into it when you go take our
early morning photos of the ocean how
about you go run in wood wood weights
photography but if you are a
photographer you need a website so you
got to go to Tim Dylan's going to hell
calm go to the bottom click on the link
we'll give you 10% off any premium plan
ok 10% off any premium plan so you could
take all your photos that are so good
that you work so [ __ ] hard on you oh
look it's the sunset on a little bridge
oh good you could take all those photos
you can put them on a website and then
maybe somebody will contact you and buy
them because you got such a good eye you
got such an eye you how'd you get that
to look so good
my father's into like taking photos of
birds now cuz he's about done he like
takes photos of birds in his backyard
and his wife makes them many things and
they hang them on a wall that's what the
last stage of its likes folks I hope
you'll stay real healthy so that you can
experience that that's the last decade
taking photos of that's a sparrow
oh is it um Tim Dylan's going to
komm go to the bottom which will give
you 10% off any premium plan I just it's
interesting man I'm getting adjusted
here to Los Angeles you can see how well
I'm getting adjusted but it's all
pretend and it's all fake but you got to
give yourself over to it cuz you'll lose
your mind you'll lose your mind if you
don't give yourself over to what it is
just accept it it's what it is folks
that's what the people want they want
song land apparently I like to believe
they don't they want to see Jimmy Fallon
and post Malone eat fettuccine alfredo
at the Times Square Olive Garden that's
what the people want they think it's
great they think it's fine and they
don't know why you got such a problem
it's fun what's the problem you want to
watch The Bachelor we like it we like
The Bachelor you know and I have friends
you have regular friends I speak to
regular I know when you hear the show
you think that I don't I talk to a lot
of different kinds of people and there's
a lot of people out there that like to
show that don't agree with what I say
and that's okay there's nothing wrong
with that I prefer that but at least you
think it's funny Ryan see what Hollywood
wants now they want you to agree with
people and not laugh I'd rather you
laugh at this show and go nom I like
Disney World I don't agree with him
that's okay
but some of what I say will resonate
with you and you'll actually laugh and
think that it's funny because that's my
job is that it's it's funny or it's
interesting or maybe you do agree with
what I say or whatever or you're in the
middle who gives I don't agree with half
of what I say doesn't matter okay
you should agree about swingers but you
know that's what but the meetings I have
the people I meet now they just want you
[ __ ] to nod they just want you to
smile and nod everybody wants to be safe
what's a safe bet and they're they're
all fear fear-based
and that's where they're losing
that's where they're failing and that's
what shows like this is exceeding and
Rogin succeeding and Theo and Bert on
your mom's house and and [ __ ] and
legion of skanks and and Chang Gillis is
podcast and come town and all these
[ __ ] shows where people are genuinely
funny and authentic and [ __ ] like that
how is Nick Mullen that had ten [ __ ]
shows how has he not had ten [ __ ]
shows he because he's funny it's like
and he's he's not the type of guy that
you know he's written on a bunch of
shows but that's a guy I always thought
that somebody to let me and Nick make a
show I always want you know you know I
mean now I look back I'm like why did I
think that but I always wanted to do
that Nick was gonna be the first person
I had he was the first guy I had in the
pilot you know you know on my writer you
know and we were going Nick had this
idea where we were doing this tour of
Long Island right so we wanted to set
this fake fundraiser because the whole
thing was about Lorne I was like
obsessed with Billy Joel right if you
wanted have this fake fundraiser where
all these kids have this disease that
nobody understood what it was but we're
gonna like Photoshop them to all kind of
look like Billy Joel
and we didn't know if anyone who's gonna
notice and the fundraiser was gonna be
we're gonna have a bunch of dillagi
impersonators we're gonna have a realist
fund rich because stage real fundraiser
and have a bunch of Billy Joel
impersonators get in a fistfight about
who was more Billy Joel and they were
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of each other in
front of real people and it was all
gonna be a fundraiser for these kids who
had a disease that made them look like
Billy Joel and when we explained this
idea we explained this idea this is
Nick's idea is brilliant and when we
explain you because I wanted something
with Billy Joel and I want it like a
fake Billy Joel fundraiser and I was
like Billy Joel impersonators need to be
involved and it's like what if we gave
these kids of disease or made them all
look like Billy Joel we had all these
little kids it'll kind of look like
we explain this idea uh to the
production company you could have said
you wanted to do a music video at
Auschwitz and it would have gotten a
better reception then when we brought up
this idea but it's still one of the
funniest things ever we had this idea
where I would get in a rowboat to try to
make it to Plum Island which is the
disease research facility in Long Iowa
they clearly like breeding some you know
God Only Knows you're doing tests on
animals and [ __ ] and I was gonna get in
a boat with the Long Island medium we're
gonna try to get her to do it she
wouldn't do it but or Alexa ray Joel I'm
Lorna medium and I was just gonna get in
a boat and try to row to elect Tom
Island singing Billy Joel songs trying
to wrote upon but nobody wants to have
any fun you know nobody wants to nobody
wants to do anything so so [ __ ] it guys
listen we appreciate you the people that
are into the patreon the patreon is like
it's the idea it's the kind of the me
accepting that if we want to do real
funny [ __ ] we want to do this [ __ ] we
want to do we're kind of gonna have to
do we're sitting in a garage now it's 2
o'clock in the [ __ ] morning this is
where we started to make these videos a
year above over a year ago and this is
where the funny [ __ ] that we've done in
the last year has come out of it hasn't
come out of a network it hasn't come out
of a writers room
it shows come out of me and been sitting
here doing funny [ __ ] and people are
[ __ ] and we've got millions and
millions of views and people like
Stanhope and Christ's shirt and Rogan
and Noor McDonald people people that we
respect and look up to you like those
people have all said this is really
funny [ __ ] and that is just the route
we're gonna have to take it'll be harder
it'll be longer and it's just the route
because whatever is gonna happen
whatever they're gonna do out there and
I just turned down I was just asked to
do something stand-up wise I turned it
down
the money was [ __ ] but it was also like
these things that people are doing or
not
gonna be good and I didn't want to do
something that I was completely like
everyone I talk to you about this
including some of the other people doing
it we're like yeah it's gonna suck but
we're just gonna do it because that's to
what it is and I was like well I don't
want to do it that I don't want to be in
this business if I'm that [ __ ]
cynical or I just go well I'm just gonna
do it because everyone else is doing it
it's gonna suck and I'm gonna hate it
you know and it'll be bad but it's just
what you do man we're all just desperate
and we're all just you know they can
they can give us they can give us a bowl
of gruel and we thank them you know
thank you for the gruel please may I
have some more may have another 15
minutes sir
can I'll just get another 10 minutes to
do my joke sir no no no at a certain
point you gotta you gotta just say [ __ ]
it what we've been doing is been working
we're gonna keep doing that you know and
if any big Network wants to write me a
check I will delete this episode you
understand me
vanilla comedy calm for all the dates I
am going to be at the stress factory in
New Jersey September 5th to the 7th I'm
going to be a go bananas in Cincinnati I
think right the next weekend which is
like September 11 the 12th or something
I'm gonna be all over the place I'm
gonna be in the side splitters in Tampa
in October I'm gonna be in Providence
Rhode Island I'm gonna be everywhere
please rate review subscribe to the
podcast on Apple podcast sorry YouTube
demons that there's no video I know
you're gonna flip out go [ __ ] off go
watch something else then okay you
[ __ ] want me to go we couldn't do it
this week you gotta get more video it's
gonna happen we're getting more video
we're doing everything that we [ __ ]
can here we got a limited budget
we got limited [ __ ] we're trying to make
everything happen and
you know Tim Jay Dylan di ll when on
Instagram on Twitter if you can't
subscribe to the page hon that's fine
too
so tell people about the show tell
people that it's funny tell people that
it's good keep listening to it you know
that's all that we could really ask you
to do you know I mean that's it I mean I
can't ask you to do more but you know
will ya so I gotta go now because
tomorrow I get to get on an American
Airlines flight and find a Raleigh to
good night's comedy club very excited
about that hopefully people are there
hopefully they want to laugh all the
college kids that just got back you know
to Raleigh whatever
hopefully you there you know you're
gonna be excited you can enjoy it I feel
like it's a lot of preppy I'll do well
with those people I'll call them out you
know for whatever you know they'll enjoy
that it is what it is folks you know
real fun set at the store tonight man
I'm feeling like it's gonna LA I'm gonna
find a way to make la my home and I it's
just a very it's a tough city only
because it is run by Satan that's the
only thing about it but the weather is
nice goodbye